[Applause]
nice try all right hey y'all this is
Blake Shelton you're watching certified
country with Sophie shall I see
[Music]
welcome to Tishomingo Oklahoma home of
Blake Shelton and now his new restaurant
ol red hey guys I'm sobytia' Lacey this
is certified country and today we are
here for the grand opening of Blake's
new hot spot so the first thing I was
looking for when I came in here was the
Blake's bar sign from Gwen's Grammy
performance where is it well it's in my
house but man I need to bring that down
here a lot of stuff that's in here it's
from my house anyway oh yeah
[Music]
I see you guys come down here all the
time with the boys it's got to be cool
to have this awesome community to come
to with that it's been a lot of fun for
me to be the one to get to expose them
to this out in the country basically you
know and they've they love us so much
her entire family and now and I say her
family I mean all I'm talking about the
kids the the mom the dad the brother you
know there's times when we've had like
holiday gatherings and I'm talking about
30 plus family members from her side
from my side it we have so much fun I
don't think you should be able to have
that much fun it's probably not legal in
California probably the kids clearly
adore you you're putting them in music
videos that spark like a paternal
instinct in you I think the voice
sparked that in me if anything it early
on and I've just kind of rolled with it
I never thought in a million years when
I signed on to do that show that I would
ever be so defensive first season or to
man I couldn't help it I would just lose
my mind when I would see somebody
picking on a kid you know and so I think
that I think that was that that part of
me that was always in there you know you
see yourself having more kids nice try
all right
the babies
so the album Texoma Shore is out
November third so the last one was super
personal where's this one out in the
spilling tea department I don't think
this one is is as personal there's a
song or two on there that are directly
you know personal and but you know for
the most part I just I just made an
album that feels like I feel right now
that's just happy and going with the
flow it might be able like one or two
songs on there that kind of feel like
you know lost my dog and my wife it's
really just more about overall feel and
I had no plans of putting out an album
this year at all okay quick listen it
just happened you know I think I'll name
the dogs is really what set this ball
rolling you know because I planned on
still being in the middle of releasing
music off if I'm honest and that was the
plan it was a labels plan the managers
plan and I called one dance that hey
guys and when when this current single
runs its course screw it let's come out
with a new album so I caught everybody
off guard which is another indicator of
how excited I am about this one
I need duets on the album that you can
choose no no are there duets on the
album that you can't tease no
[Music]
this is ol red named of course for
Blake's hit song this is a bar
restaurant a live music space one that
Blake says he hopes to come back to and
keep performing at for years to come
talk to me a little bit about Tishomingo
it's your adopted hometown you weren't
born here tell me why this place is so
special to you Tishomingo has kind of
been in the area also that I grew up in
this is where you came if you wanted to
go sand bass fishing in the spring or
wild boar hunting you know that all that
stuff is down in this area so it's
always you know just been another one of
my spots I hung out in growing up in
Oklahoma so you know when I decided to
move back home in 2006 from Nashville
found a piece of land here that I
thought I really liked and just jumped
on it tell me when you decided that you
wanted to get into the restaurant
business I did feel like there was a
need for something like that and in this
community not just a restaurant but
maybe a tourist top attraction because
it gotten pretty pretty tumbleweed ii
around here last couple of years yeah
yeah it did and I don't think anybody
would argue with that and now all of a
sudden it's it's healthy again and you
see people everywhere and there's cars
parked around and and you know there's a
bar and Tishomingo I mean there's a bar
you can get a Bloody Mary over here I
want yeah oh yeah we're gonna get one
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching be
sure to click like and subscribe for
more from ET and check back every Friday
for new episodes of certified country
thank you so much thank you little buddy
oh she's just little it's okay
[Music]